so s20 Fe was the people's champ S21 Fe
was a little late and a little lacking
s22 Fe literally never came out not a
great Trend but s23 Fe is here and I
want to know if you'd pick this Fan
Edition over the regular s23 so this is
$200 less than the regular s23 but it's
$200 more than the a54 so this is a $600
phone so for that price you get the
build quality from the a54 which is
Gorilla Glass on the front and back
metal rails a flat 1080p 120hz display
but a bit brighter and then it gets
upgraded triple cameras last year's
Flagship processor the Snapdragon 8 gen
1 and it trades a little bit of battery
capacity for wireless charging it also
has the optical fingerprint reader
instead of the ultrasonic ones from the
flagships and it's got slightly thicker
bezels all the way around but this is
basically 90% of the flagship phone for
$200 less but the thing is Samsung
strategy is to offer you a phone at
basically every price from $2,000 to
$200 so no matter which one you go with
they'll be happy